[Music]
[Applause]
tony dungy kind enough to join us hall
of fame coach and uh won some super
bowls as a player with the steelers as a
head coach with the colts and the rooney
rule was created uh back in 2002 that
was a reaction to when tony got fired
with the buccaneers dennis green and the
minnesota vikings also got fired as well
and tony joins us we'll get to that
topic in a moment here tony i'm curious
how much of an advantage it'll be for
sean mcvay having already coached in a
super bowl
well it's it's interesting uh and
sean said after their super bowl lost to
new england he did some things wrong he
overthought things in those two weeks he
if he went back he would do things a
little differently and i know he's
learned from that
i was in cincinnati
on wednesday interviewing zach taylor
zach taylor was on that staff he was at
that game he he did it too so he wasn't
the head coach but he was there and he
was watching everything sean did he saw
the schedule he uh had the benefit of
being there also so i think it's going
to be minimal advantage you have two
guys that kind of went through it at the
same time in 2019
and also coaches have talked about you
if you go in with a game plan you have
to be ready to adjust your game plan
because yeah your game plan really is
dictated by what happens in the game
itself like you can't just say this is
what we're doing we're going to continue
to do that right you fall into that
trend no you can't but i will tell you
this and sean's right that two weeks can
get to you you're used to planning and
taking a week and go and now you've got
an extra week and you start to
second-guess yourself i know i've told
you the story we went a whole week
saying we're not going to let devin
hester touch the ball and then the
second week i started thinking about it
here at chapel service the guy talks
about david and goliath and he said you
can't be scared of the giant and at the
last minute i changed my mind and said
you know what guys saturday night before
the game
i hope we lose the toss we're going to
kick off the devin hester when we pound
him
we're going to send a message they're
going to know we mean business if we'd
only had a week devin hester would have
never touched the ball
wait are you blaming the the preacher
who's the tablet i am i blamed him he
takes total responsibility for it and
then you know what he told me afterwards
dan he said no no you got the wrong
message from that it wasn't that david
wasn't afraid you got to know the weak
spot he hit goliath right between the
eyes you gotta go for the weak spot
that's why i wish you'd have told me
that saturday night yeah i think this is
the anniversary
i think 15 years ago it is yeah 15 years
ago tonight what did you feel like after
winning a super bowl
you know i i won one as a player and and
it was a real thrill and it was great to
be part of it but when you're uh the
head coach
and you win the game and you get up on
that podium and you're looking down and
you see not only your players but your
staff down there and their families and
then you look up in the stands and you
see your fans and they're holding up
signs and then you go back to the parade
in your city and you realize this is
bigger than just a team accomplishment
you felt i felt like man
you know the city of indianapolis the
state of indiana the earth says
everybody our whole organization you
just feel really really proud and then
of course my year it was even a little
bit more special lovie smith and i and
african-american coaches for 40 years uh
first time anybody had been in that game
uh and then you get notes i got a
telegram i mentioned to you in the past
got a telegram from bill russell saying
congratulations welcome to the club
and uh
you can't put you can't put words to
that
but
how much pressure are you carrying
in in a situation even though it was
lovey smith so two african-american
coaches
but did was there extra pressure of
being african-american head coach in the
super bowl
i think there would have been had loving
not been on the other side there would
have been you know we we knew at that
point hey history is going to be made
somebody's going to win it and you know
we're going to be able to say you know
these african-american coaches can coach
on the same level but had i've been in
there by myself i think i would have
felt a little bit more hey we've got to
win this just to show people we can do
this i was wondering about coaches who
don't call plays
are you aware of what the plays are are
you listening oh
absolutely okay and you have the final
say on everything you know tom moore
would call our offensive plays and i'm
sitting there and i'm saying no time i
want to run or i want to get the ball to
marvin harrison in this situation ron
meeks was calling my defensive calls hey
no i want a blitz i want to put pressure
on him 90 of the time you're on the same
page and you've been in the meetings and
you know what the game plan is for these
situations but there are times when you
know you
you just impose your will hey i want to
do this we're ahead by eight points tom
we're going to run the ball three times
and kick a field goal i know you don't
want to do that but that's what we're
going to do
but you've got to do this in a in a
small window though tony because you're
you know so you're going to have a play
getting ready to be called into peyton
and then you're there listening and then
you could say no no no i don't i don't
want to run that so peyton's waiting for
the call to come in yeah no and good
coach you're thinking ahead it's not in
the moment you wait until the moment i'm
talking to tom before the play runs hey
if we do this we want to think about
that yeah you're involved and did peyton
over rule you how often would peyton go
no well
well he always had the final say and
because we're gonna send tom would send
in three plays hey run left run right or
throw and you know he had that choice
of course he sees something different
he's going to audible to it that was the
beauty of our system we got the plays in
so fast with the no huddle that he's got
20 25 seconds at the line to run what he
wants but we we all know we we kind of
know the game plan
we're talking to tony dunchy the hall of
fame uh coach
when your defensive coach defensive
minded former defensive back what would
you do
to uh joe burrow or try to get him to do
or not do
i think all of these guys uh they're so
talented right now the weaponry is so
good you have to make them make a lot of
throws you can't uh kind of like people
were playing kansas city you can't give
up the two play touchdown drive the 80
yard touchdown pass so you've got to
make them make a lot of throws and then
you've got to get pressure to me that is
going to be the whole key with this game
the the
offensive line of the bengals they
played well against kansas city they
struggled against tennessee this is the
best defensive line they're going to see
how are they going to handle aaron
donald leonard floyd von miller and
create protection if they give
borrow time they're going to pick this
secondary part as good as those players
are as good as jalen ramses they can't
cover those guys if pearl has time i
still go back to what cincinnati did to
kansas city in the second half and for
the life of me i can't understand why
you don't run the ball i get if they're
going to play seven defensive backs and
have a spy on mahomes why don't i just
take some clock away run the football
well kansas city doesn't like to run and
everybody knows that and unfortunately
sometimes you have to the other thing
that i thought kansas city didn't do if
you
think back to that first half
very few long passes get the ball out
quick guys are open hit them take the
seven yard gain in the second half
patrick wasn't doing that and i don't
think it was because the guys were
covered it's because okay i'm a little
bored with that six yard gain and that
seven yard gain let me see if i can get
one now that and the game tightened up a
little bit and i need a big play and uh
he passed up a lot of open guys in the
second half yeah i'm with you on that i
think ego got in the way i i really do
it's funny you mention it though because
when we had the chiefs on earlier and
rodney as you know rodney harris and i
was at the stadium so he's doing a lot
of the interviews and stuff and i said
ask andy reid this for me this is one
question i'd like to ask if i was there
you've got my homes you've got all these
receivers and you love to throw is it
hard for you to call a running play
because you want to see patrick mahomes
with the ball in his hand because you
have chances to run and andy's always
been a pass first guy uh all the way
back to philadelphia but i think it's
getting harder and harder for those guys
to call runs
your initial reaction to the brian
flores lawsuit was what
you know uh i have not read the lawsuit
yet it's 58 pages i want to read the
whole thing my initial reaction was
frustration and brian flores is was is
saying i believe
he is saying what a lot of people are
talking about casually in conversation
he just brought it he's frustrated with
the the system right now and i'm gonna
have a lot more to say on this next week
but uh i think right now the nfl has a
problem because you've got
african-american employees
especially coaches who are frustrated
with with the system right now
if brian flores had called you before
filing that lawsuit
what would you told him
um
probably
make sure you know what you're doing and
this is what you want to do and this is
how you want to bring it to life it's
interesting john you mentioned 2002
johnny cochran and cyrus mary had a
meeting with the nfl and they said hey
we've got some issues here
we've got african-american coaches being
fired with winning records being fired
in the playoffs we've got limited access
to african-american coaches getting into
the system
these guys are upset this was 20 years
ago and he said we need to sit down at
the table and you need to listen to them
because the next step is going to be
litigation and i remember johnny cochran
saying this very very loudly nfl you do
not want
litigation and uh the first pilot
alliance came into effect we had some
things going on the rooney rule gets put
in place diversity committees those type
of things so uh i think johnny cochran
kind of predicted that this might might
happen one day chris carter was on good
morning football and nfl network today
and he said
he was asked about what do we do how do
we make this better and i'm paraphrasing
but it was let's groom these coaches
these assistant coaches these minority
coaches on
how what to expect in the interviews
prepare them better and i don't know if
if you can just sort of wave a wand like
that and go we're going to prepare eric
bienemy to be a head coach i i don't
know if you can do that but i did you
know i was interested with what chris
carter had to say i i i can appreciate
that my personal opinion is the problem
is not on the supply side the problem is
on the demand side
and there's one and i i have one
i'm going to be on a soapbox about this
until they change it i think the process
is flawed
for everybody and that's why we have a
lot of bad decisions made and we have a
lot of one-year two-year hires
and it really hurts minority candidates
and i'll tell you why we are
interviewing these coaches
during the playoffs
and i think that's terribly wrong it's
terribly unfair
you
you you cannot
tell me that i can prepare
to play the kansas city chiefs and i'm
trying to stop them as a defensive
coordinator and then i can take a
timeout on friday afternoon at four
o'clock and interview with you dan and
you're asking me questions about your
organization and your team and you want
me to be specific about how i'm going to
make your team better and then after
that interview go back to my thoughts on
the chiefs and
no one
can be as prepared in that situation as
the person who's not in the playoffs
i was in the playoffs in minnesota three
years interviewed a couple of times
didn't get the jobs that you one year we
didn't make it i had three interviews
with the tampa bay buccaneers i was able
to be very specific about what i wanted
to do i ended up getting that job i
don't think it was a coincidence um
when people say
so-and-so came in and blew me away in
the interview well i could blow you away
too if i had a week to look at your
roster and look at your past drafts and
look at
how i would do it and set things up and
make a powerpoint presentation and now
you're eric and these african-american
coaches who are who's getting the
interviews you tell me eric the enemy
leslie fraser byron leftwich todd bowles
these aren't coaches who aren't in the
playoffs because if you're
african-american and you're not in the
playoffs you're probably not getting an
interview have you talked to the
commissioner have you conveyed this to
the question
i've said this for five years i think
this is wrong i i think uh interviewing
coaches in the middle of the playoffs
it's detrimental to them and it's
detrimental to the team because you
don't get a good impression of of
someone that
can't be prepared as prepared as someone
who has had a week and a half to do
nothing but prepare for your interview
yeah i can't you know everybody keeps
saying eric the enemy deserves a job
you know i'm all i'm all for that it
feels like we're missing something here
tony why does eric be enemy not have a
head coaching i know he's reportedly
going to interview with the saints i
thought he was going to get the vikings
job so what's this year three of eric b
enemy doesn't have a head coaching job
why is that um i i don't know why but
all i can do is go back to my situation
and i heard a lot of the same things in
the 90s
well tony dungy is very smart he's a
good coach he's been in some good
systems he's worked for chuck noll he's
worked for marty schottenheimer he's
worked for denny green
but he his personality he doesn't come
across well in the interviews he's not a
overly aggressive guy he's not this he's
not that he doesn't interview well no
that's what i heard
about myself
30 years ago or 25 years ago
and
um
i i don't know you know it's that i
wasn't exactly what people were looking
for i'll give you a perfect example i
interviewed with an organization thought
it was going really well the last
question the guy asked me he said
i understand you don't use profanity you
don't raise your voice much how are you
going to motivate my guys and i said
i'll do it the way i always have and the
way my dad did it with me i'm going to
show them that i care about them that i
know what i'm doing that i love them and
i think i'll get that mutual respect and
they'll be motivated that's what i've
done with my defenses over the years guy
looked across at me dan said that won't
work in the nfl that's not what i'm
looking for
well and then the word came out that i
didn't interview well
the next year i go to tampa
they asked me kind of the similar
question
i answer the same way mr glazer said
that's how i talk to my boys that that's
who i want as my head coach
so i think that's what eric bennemy
needs somebody that just says you are
the kind of guy i'm looking for did you
send a picture of your super bowl ring
to that guy who said that your style
won't work in the nfl we actually played
against them quite often uh in in in the
upcoming years and he actually told me
at an owners meeting i i was wrong
[Laughter]
what was his name again tony
i can't go into that i don't want to
throw anybody under the bus
do you do you ever run into tom brady in
tampa since you lived there like at the
supermarket
uh not at the supermarket or any of
those places i've seen time a couple
times and uh clyde christensen who was
on my staff is the quarterback coach
there so he he puts us in touch with
each other uh periodically and tom has
he's been amazing down here he's turned
the
turn the city around and and the bucks
fans around he really has safe travels
to los angeles always great my best to
uh the family always great to talk to
you
thank you brother i miss you you know
that thank you tony miss you too
and some good stories there